wenn der Wind stark bläst könnten Sie
hier an der Nordseeküste in
Schleswig-Holstein besonders viel grünen
Strom produzieren theoretisch doch
gerade an solchen Tagen werden Windräder
immer wieder gedrosselt oder sogar ganz
abgeschaltet der Grund die Netze sind
überlastet
der Strom kann nicht über
Hochspannungsleitungen abtransportiert
werden
wir haben hier die Situation dass wir
nach wie vor 10 bis 15 Prozent
Abschaltung haben und das ist bei einem
Windpark dieser Größenordnung eine
erhebliche Menge die wir sehr gut
volkswirtschaftlich auch bräuchten und
nutzen können
der Verbraucher zahlt für den
nichteinsten Strom trotzdem denn wenn
Windparkbetreiber ihre Windräder
abschalten bekommen Sie eine
Entschädigung die wird dann als
sogenanntes Netzentgelt auf den
Strompreis aufgeschlagen stattdessen
sollte der überschüssige Windstrom
genutzt werden um Wasser zu erwärmen und
damit zu heizen fordern forscher der
Universität Kiel dadurch könnte die
Region bis zu 15% Erdgas einsparen haben
sie errechnet
wir können in Konstellationen kommen
nächstes Jahr im Winter dass wir einfach
nicht genügend Erdgas überhaupt zur
Verfügung haben das ist echt ein echten
Problem ich meine das Leute keine
Heizung haben aber auf nicht laufende
Windmühlen schauen das ist eine
groteske-situation ich in der wir uns
befinden
in Wilster haben Sie deshalb im
städtischen Hallenbad die Wasser- und
Raumtemperatur abgesenkt Öffnungszeiten
verkürzt sie müssen Gas sparen gerne
würden sie den überschüssigen Windstrom
verwenden doch es gibt einen Haken
also momentan ist es relativ schwierig
diesen Windstrom zu nutzen weil ganz
viele Abgaben auf diesen Stromlast wie
zum Beispiel Stromsteuer
Durchleitungsgebühren für den Strom und
diese Abgaben müssten eigentlich weg
damit es auch sinnvoll wäre und auch
attraktiv ist für die Bäder diesen Strom
zu nutzen
Energiemanager Wolf rechnet vor addiert
er zum Strom und Gaspreis Netzentgelte
und steuern würde er für den Windstrom
unterm Strich über 23 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bezahlen für das Gas
zahlt er nur gut 17 Cent absurd denn der
Gaspreis ist aktuell deutlich in die
Höhe geschossen
das Netz an Geld für den Windstrom ist
10 mal so hoch wie beim Gas in meinem
Beispiel wir müssen hier ran da sind
riesenpotenziale den Windstrom
attraktiver und günstiger zu machen
preiswerter zu machen wir brauchen auch
Entscheidungen dringend Entscheidungen
weil Herr Habeck gesagt jede
Kilowattstunde zählt und das gilt auch
hierfür doch Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
hat eine andere Priorität
zwei drei gerade hat er einen neuen
Abschnitt einer Stromtrasse im Norden
von Schleswig-Holstein in Betrieb
genommen
von hier aus will er grünen Windstrom in
den industriereichen Süden Deutschlands
leiten
guter Tag weil er zwei Sachen zeigt erst
einmal wird ja eine der großen
windregionen jetzt angeschlossen an das
starke Netz und das soll ja noch mehr
Wind ausgebaut werden also man muss sich
klar machen der ganze Windstrom wird ja
nicht für die Region produziert sondern
für Deutschland
doch der milliardenschwere Ausbau der
Übertragungsleitungen von Nord nach
Süddeutschland verzögert sich seit
Jahren die Fertigstellung der
stromautobahn südlingen etwa die Grünen
Windstrom von der Nordsee nach Bayern
und Baden-Württemberg transportieren
soll war eigentlich für dieses Jahr
geplant nun soll es erst 2028 soweit
sein eine zweite Trasse der Südost Link
von Sachsen-Anhalt nach Bayern soll 2027
in Betrieb gehen fraglich ob die Termine
zu halten sind
dann bisher wurde kein einziger Meter
gebaut Bürger vor Ort wehren sich
vehement gegen die geplanten
Stromautobahnen die
Genehmigungsverfahren laufen schon viele
Jahre der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
versucht erst gar nicht das schön zu
reden
mit dem Atomausstieg wurde gesagt sind
die Stromnetze fertig die großen
Stromautobahnen sollen dann gebaut sein
tja ich stelle fest wie so vieles das
ist nicht erledigt worden und jetzt
beschleunigen wir die Prozesse
[Musik]
da wo der Strom hinkommen soll hier nach
Bayern gibt es jetzt schon in einigen
Regionen zu viel Strom der nicht genutzt
werden kann der kommt aus
Photovoltaikanlagen viele Anlagen müssen
regelmäßig abgeschaltet werden auch die
von Melanie Husemann in Aurach bei
Nürnberg
[Applaus]
von den 314 Tagen in diesem Jahr ist die
Anlage schon 172 Tage abgeschaltet
worden das heißt so ca 55%
sind ja ein Strom sind weggeschmissen
worden der Grund die regionalen
Netzbetreiber kommen mit dem Ausbau der
Stromleitungen nicht hinterher wir haben
gedacht wir tun was Gutes und wir
investieren in eine Photovoltaikanlage
aber wir haben nicht gewusst dass es
irgendwann so ein Drama wird dass man
den Strom einfach nicht mehr weiter
transportieren kann weil die
Infrastruktur fehlt
in der Leitstelle des regionalen
verteilnetzbetreibers fürchten sie dass
die Abschaltungen eher noch zunehmen
werden es Fehler an Geld und Material um
die Leitungen vor Ort auszubauen den
überschüssigen Strom würden Sie gerne
zwischenspeichern doch das rechne sich
nicht
wir als Verteilnetzbetreiber würden
gerne in Batteriespeicher investieren
der gesetzliche Rahmen dafür ist aber so
unpassend ausgestattet dass wir die
Investitionskosten und die
Betriebskosten dafür nicht
zurückbekommen würden
nechlin in Brandenburg hier zeigt sich
Stromspeichern das kann auch
funktionieren wenn das Netz überlastet
ist nutzen Sie den überschüssigen
Windstrom für einen Wärmespeicher um
damit zu heizen dafür haben die
Betreiber ihren Windpark direkt mit dem
örtlichen Nahwärmenetz verbunden und
eine eigene Leitung gelegt
wir nehmen hier den Teil der praktisch
unverkäuflich ist man nimmt einfach dann
diese Mengen
pack sie in ein Wärmespeicher ja und hat
dann Energie für mehrere Wochen zum
Heizen
man muss überhaupt nichts ab Regeln
nicht einer einzige Kilowattstunde muss
man ab Regeln man kann das alles Nutzen
der Strom wird mit älteren Windanlagen
produziert für die das staatliche
Förderprogramm ausgelaufen ist bei
Abschaltungen gibt es keine
Entschädigung für den Windparkbetreiber
daher zahlt es sich aus den
überschüssigen Strom ans örtliche
Nahwärmenetz zu liefern auch die
Dorfbewohner profitieren Sie zahlen
aktuell 50% weniger als für Öl
ist eine super Ersparnis und einfach
weil ich habe hier auch 5000 Euro Öl ja
gebraucht das ist ja viel und dadurch
dass ich jetzt angeschlossen bin brauche
ich nachher nicht so viel wir können uns
unser Bier noch leisten
grünen Strom intelligent nutzen statt
ihn wegzuwerfen in echlin in Brandenburg
machen sie es vor